joining me here on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line is uh
the head coach of my michigan wolverines
um and i couldn't be more excited about
what is going on
with the wolverines getting set to take
on villanova in the sweet 16 he is the
head coach jajuan howard how are you
coach
hey what's up rich i'm doing well man
how are you i'm better for talking to
you i'm not gonna lie i'm not gonna lie
so uh let's jump into it here we had
chris webber on yesterday
and he talked about what it meant to him
to be there what did it mean to you to
see him there
it's been everything uh to me and to the
staff and players uh to see chris being
back for his first michigan basketball
game
during a very highlight moment a very
tough competitive game
speaking of versus tennessee yes
to be able to get that victory and
knowing that you know we have my brother
c webb in the building you know that was
that's one of those special moments man
that i'm always going to remember in
chairs
as a head coach at the university of
michigan yeah and it just seemed again
um obviously before
you went into the locker room and where
it was with you were celebrating with
your
players just seeing him and you and i
guess ray jackson as well like
three-fifths of the fab five
together like that was just uh
spectacular you know and yeah yeah
you know and so ray got out of the way
it seemed to so the two of you guys
could have your moment it seemed like
that for a quick second
correct well no yes you know you're
absolutely right uh ray first is uh so
selfless he's always been that way since
our times uh at michigan and you know
ray had been to a michigan game before
um surprised me you know like in 2019 my
first
season with michigan as the head coach
and at that time you know ray has been
also behind the scenes
uh during those moments uh helping you
know see webb uh with this you know
transitioning back to the school uh to
to visit michigan and so
ray you know wanted that moment to be
for us uh for chris and i'm speaking of
and um i just really applaud you know
both guys for you know taking time from
their schedule away from their families
and just being present
man i love them both you know i love all
of them
jimmy king
jaylen rose is that our first game yes
versus colorado state
you know those moments man the highlight
moments man just to be there
for the players you know because it's
not about me it's bigger than me
and but then you know being a you know
student athlete in michigan you know i'm
sure that's the highlight moments for
them too because they remember their
time
during their tournament runs and you
know how what it meant for them and
their growth
yeah what what
i mean
what what are the current michigan
players
say
you know when when somebody like c webb
comes in or ray jackson or jalen you
know your teammates from back in the day
what did what did they say to you did
they say anything to you do you have a
conversation with them about it at all
yes uh you know and that's you know that
conversation started this morning
believe it or not uh you know moussa you
know just talked about how excited he
was seeing chris webber and then also
knowing like you know the things that
was said in the locker room uh he
highlighted you know some of his words
as far as his message given to the guys
and so
i i never once know talked about like
hey you know when you're five five we
you know we did it this way or uh this
is how it should be done because you
know fat five has had so much success um
you know i never address our players
that way because you know at that moment
you know once you get to talk about
as a coach but when i did this and i did
that
sometimes you sort of lose them but you
know i've always the only thing i've
shared with them was you know my time in
michigan was special and i had a chance
to experience it with you know some
great teammates and
those relationships
has lasted a lifetime for me and for
them and so that's why i've always
you know talked to our players about you
know these moments of the hard practices
the
you know the wins the losses
you know the the trips the bus rides the
locker room talks
um the mills when we share together
this is the brotherhood that you are
gonna you know and the bond is you're
creating now
it's it's gonna be something that you
know that
hopefully in 30 years from now you guys
get a chance to reflect on
um but you still will always remain in
attack as a family
a few minutes here with the head coach
of michigan wolverines basketball
getting set to take on villanova in the
sweet 16 juwan howard here on the rich
eisen show also could he not help but
notice and i did make mention of it here
on this program was the moment you had
on the handshake line with kennedy
chandler of tennessee
uh i did not know chris mentioned this
weber c webb mentioned this yesterday
that you
tried to recruit
uh kennedy to michigan and obviously he
went to tennessee how did that moment
occur
with you and him when he kind of just
fell into your arms sobbing after
michigan
beat tennessee
coach well uh you know for the post game
you know we lined up and uh
rick barnes you know special man great
coach hall of fame in my opinion uh you
know we've changed you know some kind
works with one another along with his
staff and shaking hands
and then at the end
as i address you know each and every
player you know kenny was the last one
and and i noticed that
he was starting to get emotional and
you know all i could think about hey you
know i'm a father um
you know i can't i'm also a head coach
and i understand you know the highs and
the lows of the game and
being competitive you know i get that
that moment as well and so it was my
time to really step up and help a young
man at need who needed comfort and i i
didn't think
you know any anything of it um but it
just came from a pure place and
kennedy is you know obviously you know
we all know a super talented young man
on the floor but he's also a high
character individual and um
he needed me i thought he needed me at
that time well i you know and i think
part of it might be also a conversation
a starter uh based on
you know uh a previous handshake line
moment that occurred
just about a month ago coach and and i'm
wondering have you come
how did you come through
those five games where you were
watching uh and how you might be
different
now
coaching
based on that experience at all well
well that's a great question and during
that time you know i got a chance to
learn
um grow
and and get stronger and how and how
that all came about was
i got a chance to reflect uh reflect on
you know those moments of how i can be a
better person and
um and then i wanted to you know find
answers on how i can grow
and so i wouldn't get assault counseling
and i mean i've had counseling before as
a player in the league and nba i'm
speaking of
and then
um
with that moment
of counseling you know i i got a chance
to learn how to become a better person a
better version of myself and then also i
become a better coach
and that two-week process was a
a loan moment
each and every day i was painful
because you know i knew amount of people
that i hurt
and
and also with that
i wasn't going to make any excuse for it
it was just a time of action as far as
okay it's time to grow it and get better
so that's the the moment that i use
that's the time you know being away from
my team that i used
in order for me to
be a better version of myself
juwan howard here on the rich eisen show
a couple more minutes left uh before i
send you uh back into your day there in
san antonio
um
eli brooks was on the team that lost to
villanova have you had a conversation
with him about um
you know
getting uh getting a piece back at all
like is he somebody that you're turning
to in particular senior leadership right
now
uh with a very difficult task in front
of you
coach well
no we haven't had a conversation about
it but i've heard you know some talks
and
things that he said about at this time
you know reflecting on you know his game
versus uh villanova and uh what that
moment is like being in the national
championship game
but um
eli brooks you know i just have to you
know just mention about you know how
he's elevated his play during the
tournament and how he's been a special
leader for the michigan basketball not
just this year
last year
and the year before that
um
you know he's one of the best leaders
i've ever been around xavier simpson is
being one of them
eli is a special player
but i what he's had to do this year
not having you know uh isaiah livers or
austin davis or mike smith shawnee brown
franz wagner uh this man came back to
school uh for a reason he wanted to win
an uh ncaa championship
and now that we are getting closer and
closer and one game at a time you know
these young guys they want to do it for
eli because they've seen all the what
he's done all the sacrificing he's been
doing this year uh with his leadership
uh
what's he what he's been doing off the
floor uh getting guys together for lunch
breakfast working out you know hard in
the training room i mean
doing scripted conditioning in the
weight room um and practice
when when coaches not looking getting
the guys together uh getting extra work
in i mean
you know he's everything what michigan
is all about and i'm just so happy that
i get an opportunity and i know i speak
for the staff when we say this uh to
learn
to learn from a young man like eli
brooks
because you know
coaches i feel some of the best coaches
and some of the best coaching happens
when
you sit there you listen to your players
and allow them to have a voice
in their own culture
and then obviously taking out look i
want them to get a piece of villanova as
you know that already and and you know
like conor gillespie looks like he's a
chip off the old divincenzo man so
um i'm wondering how much you might be
also leaning on martelly who obviously
was a coach while you were away um for
five games i mean he he he must know jay
wright villanova philadelphia inside and
out i mean correct
yeah coach
yeah you can hear me i can yeah mm-hmm
yes yes uh coachella martelli
you know with this experience um around
college basketball for all these years
and also his success that he's had you
know at st joe's but being in that
philly area
those guys pretty much have rubbed
elbows with each other and know each
other very well
uh
he's also been a lot of his pr um
of the villanova practices and um you
know he knows he you know that program
you know like it's no other but you know
give coach
a lot of credit uh for all the years
he's been at villanova he's a hall of
fame coach and uh
you know his program has had a ton of
success and they've won two national
championships
um
that that's that program has had success
because of jay wright
well had villanova not made it um you
know it would have been michigan ohio
state joanna howard who would lebron
have rooted for in that one do you think
juwan good
that's a great question
i only asked those of you well i said he
will he will be leaning more towards
ohio state
you know i i think he probably would say
this that
no matter who wins that he feels that
he's winning
you know he'll go out the safe route you
know that's because of our brotherhood
yes
right you know relationship that we've
had you know with miami heat and the
relationship that we still have to this
day like you know brian has been one of
my biggest supporters yes like when i
was out for that two weeks you know he
reached out to me and let me know how
much he you know supports me and um and
how you know he wants me to come out and
be a better person a person from this
and grow from this and and that meant so
much man just to know that you know your
brother is cheering you on and
supporting you through tough times
well in that respect i want to play one
sound bite before before i let you go
coach howard this was chris webber
yesterday when i told him
you know what it meant to me on behalf
of all michigan fans you know i took the
liberty to speak for everybody what it
meant for me to see him back
right see him back in the fold and see
him with the michigan
m on his chest and this was his answer
to to me saying that i'll just be honest
with you seeing you next to ray jackson
and hugging out uh with juwan howard at
a michigan uh
um
ncaa tournament win and then you in the
locker room and you seeing you with the
block m on your on your
chest you know wearing the gear is
pretty cool man speaking on behalf of
all wolverines glad to see
and on behalf of myself i just thank all
the wolverines that were patient and uh
the one thing that you know again juwan
and i've never had any trouble we've
always been there but hopefully this is
the start for you know the enjoyment of
all five of us to be back which i think
it will and uh many more moments to
share but it was special my friend and
thank you over the years for uh you know
always uh pushing me forward for that of
course absolutely all five of you huh
because hey look man if if ray allen and
uh and kg are hugging it out let's go
chris
if there's water under that bridge
there's no other bridge that came water
can't be under you know what i'm
man all saying
okay what do you think
juwan what do you think it's great
it's great to hear you know those words
that come out of chris your mouth
uh knowing that you know in his heart
uh he want to see you know all five guys
back together whether
whatever form it is
if it's at a michigan basketball game
uh visit someone's
a birthday or
it's a relative outing or something like
that you know but it's with all that
experience and
and
i'm speaking of like you know
being on campus and hanging out as a
young man
um
talking about you know how what's our
next step you know after college and all
the stories
that we used to share together and talk
about you know
what happened in practice i might get
dunked on you know those are
fun cherished moments that you know no
one can take away from you and
i'm sure he's reflecting on all that and
um and it's great to hear that you know
when you mentioned about you know let's
move past it i thought that was pretty
funny
great island you know i can't leave
without saying about that one when you
talk about kg reality uh getting past
you know whatever happened over to
boston and i remember when ray uh
decided to join miami heat i was on a
miami team at that time
i know how kg and paul pearson felt um
you know that's it's it's not easy but
um knowing that when you're getting
older you know there's a life where we
all have to like move on and just
you know
uh
whatever mistake a guy
may have said bad about someone
or
whether if it's a difference that you've
had you know that's what family do they
go through those moments where you know
you grow and you move on and that's it's
nice to hear that that's what
is going to be happening soon well you
have a large role in it coach juan
howard you go uh
and go forth and keep
uh keep on advancing it's just a thrill
to watch it really is and uh i always
cherish when you take the time to call
into the show i do not take it for
granted thanks again truly no
it's it's truly an honor and
uh to be here on your show and you know
i know you're a michigan man also
through and through
um you and i you know
it's a special bond that
only us michigan people truly understand
and uh
you know being part of that amazing blue
is special and we're saying that i would
just want to leave you by with two words
yes
go blue
thank you juwan howard right back at you
i've got a big grin on my face right now
that i'm sure i love you
right back at you right back at you john
howard thanks for the call good luck
against villanova and beyond that is
juan howard everybody you bet jajuan
howard right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here